在这个视频中，我们将
把前面视频中学到的所有知识整合起来，
创建一个客户服务助手的
端到端示例。
我们将经历以下步骤：
首先，检查输入是否
触发 Moderation API。
第二，如果没有触发，
提取产品列表。
第三，如果找到了产品，
尝试查找它们。
第四，用模型回答用户的问题。
最后，把答案
再次经过 Moderation API，
如果没有被标记，
就返回给用户。
我们进行常规设置。
这里有一个额外的导入，
这是一个 Python 包，
我们将用它来构建聊天机器人 UI。
我来粘贴一个函数
"process_user_message"，
我将先运行一个示例，
然后再详细讲解这个函数。
这是我们一直使用的用户输入：
"告诉我
SmartX Pro 手机和它的摄像头，
同时也告诉我
有关电视的信息。"
让我们运行这个。
首先运行这个。
如你所见，
我们正在经历各个步骤
来回答用户的问题。
第一步是审核步骤，
第二步
是提取产品列表。
第三步是
查找产品信息。
现在有了这些产品信息，
模型正在尝试
如我们在之前视频中看到的那样
回答问题。
最后，
它将回复
再次通过 Moderation API，
确保
对用户展示是安全的。
这是我们现在熟悉的回复。
让我们稍微讲一下
正在发生什么。
我们有辅助函数
"process_user_message"。
它接受用户输入（当前消息），
以及到目前为止所有消息的数组，
这是我们构建聊天机器人 UI 时所需的。
第一步，检查输入是否
触发 Moderation API，
我们在之前的视频中已经介绍过这个。
如果输入被标记，
我们告诉用户我们
无法处理该请求。
如果没有被标记，
我们尝试提取产品列表，
如我们在之前视频中所做的那样。
然后我们尝试查找产品，
在这种情况下，
如果没有找到产品，
这将只是一个空字符串。
然后我们回答用户的问题，
将对话历史和带有
相关产品信息的新消息
传入。
获取回复后，
我们将这个回复
通过 Moderation API 再次过滤。
如果被标记，我们告诉用户
我们无法提供
这些信息。
也许我们会说类似"让我帮您联系..."
然后你可以采取后续步骤。
让我们把所有这些整合在一起，
构建一个漂亮的 UI，
并尝试进行对话。
这里有一个函数，
它会在我们与助手
交互时积累消息。
可以暂停视频，
更详细地了解
这是如何工作的。
当然，对于我们刚看到的
很长的
"process_user_message"函数，
也可以这样做。
现在我们将粘贴代码
来显示聊天机器人 UI。
运行这个后，
让我们尝试与
客户服务助手进行对话。
让我们问："你们有什么电视？"
在幕后，助手正在经历
"process_user_message"函数中
的所有步骤。
它列出了各种不同的电视。
现在让我们问：
"哪款最便宜？"
同样，它经历了
所有相同的步骤，
但这次它也将
对话历史
传入了提示中。
好的，它告诉我们
这款音响是
我们最便宜的电视相关产品。
有趣。
让我们看看最贵的是什么。
最贵的电视是
CineView 8K 电视。
让我们询问更多关于它的信息：
"告诉我更多关于它的信息。"
我们收到了
关于这台电视的更多信息。
在这个例子中，
我们综合了课程中学到的各种技术，
创建了一个包含一系列步骤的
综合系统，
用于评估用户输入、
处理它们，
然后检查输出。
通过在更大量的输入上
监控系统质量，
你可以调整这些步骤，
改善系统的
整体性能。
也许我们会发现
某些步骤的提示可以改进，
也许某些步骤
甚至不是必要的，
也许我们会找到更好的检索方法，
等等。
我们将在下一个视频中进一步讨论这些内容。